the world food program has confirmed its
resumed delivery of Aid in Sudan's
capital Khartoum deliveries have been
repeatedly delayed because of fighting
between the Army and the final military
rapid support forces operations were
suspended earlier this month after three
Aid workers were killed the U.N says
more than half of Sudan's population is
in need of humanitarian assistance we're
going to bring in asilger insta public
health specialist and a civil servant
with Sudan's Federal Ministry of Health
she fled khatum a few weeks after the
fighting began she's talking to us now
from Cairo thank you very much indeed
for being with us I want to ask you
about the kind of details we're able to
get out of Sudan at the moment it
appears to become more and more
difficult particularly when it comes to
the number of people who've died and the
kind of health conditions that are in
Sudan why is it so difficult for medical
staff in Sudan to be able to speak out
about this
um unfortunately just yesterday
um South has started arresting doctors
and they go to the surgeon and an active
member of the political party FFC and
the main speaker of the doctors Union
has been arrested and that is because of
political
um of the political issue of a forging
of a screenshot that um indicated that
he was aligning with rsf but that's
completely photoshopped like there is no
proof that he was doing that and another
thing is that
um Dr Ella nugget has always been the
voice of the truth for most uh in Sudan
and he was
um he was he was speaking for doctors he
was speaking for a public health
specialist he was speaking for the
civilian rights in the country
so he was always targeted he was part of
the Federal Ministry of not the onepoint
the health policy and planning directory
he's a surgeon and he's an active member
it's those who are speaking the truth
that are now mainly targeted if as you
say there appears to be some sort of
action being taken against medical stuff
what do you think that means for people
who are having to receive treatment in
hospitals and medical centers
um unfortunately that will of course
affect them there is no voice of the
truth it's very unsafe for medical cards
at the point because they're not only
getting targeted the rsf are losing
hospitals till this day last week they
just looted in uh they just go to two
hospitals at the Ahmed gas in hospital
was one of them and they um they kind of
threatened the doctors and them and
which which in that case was just
um very sad even for the doctors to have
the safe corridors to reach the hospital
it's almost impossible areas of
although in some areas like jazida and
other states it is relatively safe to
reach hospitals but in the conflict
remains areas in like on durman are
having an increasing number of rsf on
the grounds and the doctors cannot
really reach the hospitals even the
resistant committees who were acting as
part of a civil movement to deliver
medications are unable to leave their
houses because all also them are now
targeted the Federal Ministry of Health
have received a lot of donations about
300 tons of medical supplies that are
now in Fort Sudan and in the stores of
Jazeera and they can be relatively safe
to deliver to States in um to the States
of uh of the unaffected States but
therefore unfortunately there isn't any
safe way to deliver things to this
moment
organizations like medicines are France
which is Doctors Without Borders are
working really hard to deliver but
unfortunately even their stores has been
targeted uh even one of their doctors
was was killed in that four which is
very much
sad and it's just a really sad time for
medical who's now in Sudan because even
those who were able to speak even those
those who were able to reach the
hospitals are now more interested
and it just really breaks my heart you
know I mentioned before that you're
talking to us from Cairo and I
understand that you've left members of
your family still in Sudan why did you
feel it necessary to leave
suppose there's the safety reasons and
it's just that at this point you
wouldn't feel that it's safe enough to
for you to um stay there live there
report there and even if you want to do
anything you can do it from abroad and
it's just for me securing a better
future for myself and my family I had to
leave I took a very dangerous Journey 2
000 kilometers three buses one car a
ferry and then almost 30 hours later I
was I was
um I I then I reached Egypt but indeed
it was a very hard journey to leave yes
tell us about what your family in Sudan
is describing to you about the situation
that they're facing at the moment and of
course the people around them
um my people in in with madani are very
safe but and that's my direct family and
that's why I can't end up um
um secure but unfortunately a couple of
days ago I've been sent a video that the
rsf are trying to send medical supplies
to with madani and looks like this is
their way of trying to replenish their
photo and their image to the public by
sending medication and medical convoys
and um which is apparently just wrestles
the people in other states that were
relatively safe given that Jazeera is
the one state that is the closest to the
capital that people are fleeing to and
now it's in danger because rsf are
saying that they will get their their it
hasn't yet improved but that's a video
that they had that it shown that the
medical I can share with Al Jazeera that
shown that they were delivering
medications but I've been speaking to
members of the resisting committees in
areas
and most of them are just now in fear
because one of the members in shambad
Bahari have been arrested so there is a
direct attacks and targeting to the
civilians that are trying to keep the
peace by both parties unfortunately
which is just very sad today um on
yesterday has been filled with rsf
they've been threatening looting homes
they've been they want people to leave
their premises
um just I see oh Gators we appreciate
you talking to us on Al Jazeera and
telling us your story thank you very
much indeed for your time
thank you